una gran operación antiterrorista en
Alemania las autoridades federales
detuvieron a 25 hombres sospechosos de
organizar un ataque terrorista contra el
bundestag con el fin de derrocar al
Estado alemán lo sospechosos
pertenecerían al movimiento extrema
derecha rash bulga que niega la
existencia de la República Federal
instaurada luego de la Segunda Guerra
Mundial y de la derrota del Tercer Reich
de adolf Hitler en su cuenta de Twitter
el ministro de Justicia marco bushman se
refirió a la operación policial la
democracia ha sido defendida desde esta
mañana está en marcha una gran operación
antiterrorista el fiscal general está
investigando una presunta red terrorista
relacionada con el movimiento ciudadano
del Reich se sospecha que se planeó un
ataque armado contra los órganos
constitucionales
seis de los detenidos se produjeron en
el Estado Sureño de baviera el ministro
del interior bávaro dijo que los
sospechosos hacen parte de una de las
mayores organizaciones terroristas de
extrema derecha en los últimos años y
detalló los resultados de la operación
hoy se han registrado una gran cantidad
de lugares en baviera total de más de 20
15 presuntos participantes y un total de
seis personas de ese territorio han sido
arrestados como parte de esta operación
nacional y en parte internacional
las redadas contra ultraderechistas se
extendieron a Italia en las céntricas
ciudad de Perú ya la policía italiana
arrestó a un ex oficial del ejército
alemán de 64 años involucrado en el plan
de atacar al understack la operación en
la que participaron más de 3.000 agentes
continúa en cuatro estados alemanes Y
recuerda La desmantelación de recientes
planes de la ultraderecha contra el
gobierno alemán como el intento de
secuestro al ministro de salud